Kathy thank you so much for sitting down
with us how are you doing today good so
did you get any advice from other
filmmakers from going from an indie
movie to making a big Blosser a big
blockbuster like this um yeah I mean I
spoke to it I spotted expected patty
Jenkins I'd spoken to Rian Johnson I
spoken to James Mangold all of whom you
know had made awesome movies both Indies
and bigger movies and so they were all
really really really helpful and so
super supportive yeah and and with this
movie in particular I know there was a
little bit of tease about joking but was
he ever fully considered to be in this
movie at all like having a storyline or
whatever like that or did we like you
like I need to focus on Harley can you
talk about yeah definitely in Harley's
movie it's Harley's movie in the birds
movie yeah I gotcha gotcha and so with
this film also we're there a lot of
deleted scenes that we might be able to
see on a future blu-ray or anything like
that on that were on the cutting room
for that you were just sad that didn't
get to be in the film honestly there
weren't that many deleted scenes um one
thing that I think will be available is
a longer version of the dance the
Marilyn Monroe oh oh yeah I definitely
love to see you happy part of that so
with this in particular did WB talk to
you about trying to connect us to a
bigger world or anything like that or
did they let you have free range and
make and let you just do what you wanted
to do with this they really did they
really supported the fact that this is a
standalone film we got to create a very
different look of Gotham and you know
and and they said they're very
supportive of that and you know it
really wasn't about that it was really
about telling the best story and you
know supporting that and so while you
were on set directing this big
blockbuster movie did you have any
particularly favorite scenes or moments
while you're on set just like this is
this is awesome I can't believe I'm here
and like something that you always
remember Oh God all the time you know
all the time I mean we took some pretty
big risks in the way that we shot
certain things didn't always get the
most traditional coverage because we
wanted to you know do things in a
certain way and so whenever we were able
to pull it off I think it was extremely
exciting and you can feel the palpable
like excitement on sets
you know one of the first days actually
I think it was like the fourth day of
the shoot we did the club wonder where
Harley gets increasingly drunk you know
ends that way and she vomits in a bag
and all of that and that was just so fun
and we got it in seven takes I think and
everyone had to come together you know
there is I guess I think like four
different camera pass offs and you know
extras coming in and out and you know
women descending from the ceiling and we
had to get it all right and when we did
it was just so it just felt so good and
it was such a way to kick off the shoot
yeah and can you talk about work no we
have a margot robbie as a producer on
this you just talk about her from
working with her as an actor but also at
her and a producer type of role yeah
sure I mean she's awesome like she's so
committed both to being like the perfect
Harley Quinn but also when we should
care so much for this movie I mean she's
been working on this movie for almost
five years now yeah and last question
can you talk about working which is a
house key and and his contributions to
this movie yeah sure so he did some of
the second unit directing for our
reshoots but also his company because we
were lucky enough to get him and his
company 8711 we'd worked with that for
the entirety of the shoot and that's
because I really like the way they did
action I thought that like you know it
felt very practical I snuck creator
Jonathan you say Bo and I really got
along and we really loved like the old
Jackie Chan movies and in the way those
those stunts were done in the way that
you shoot that kind of action which is
what 8711 is sort of known for as well
and so they've been training our ladies
for mods and you know they did most of
their own stunt work and then you know
and then it was like when we when it
came time to actually adding even more
action to the movie and reshoots it was
like it was just amazing to get to work
with Chad - I gotta say this was one of
particularly one of my favorite action
movies from the DC like I think the
action was top-notch and Philip the last
thing I keep saying last question but my
very last question this movie ends it
sets up some it sets up our heroes to go
off on their own adventures you just
talked about do you have any ideas of
what you'd like to see in a birds of
prey 2 movie I don't know I mean I just
I think it's Obie
fun to see that dynamic again for sure
and you know be fun to just like just be
with those characters more and see how
they interact with each other and on all
the different misadventures they get up
to yes I would definitely obviously I
thought it was very good choice to do
just to introduce Black Canary and
hunters into this world that we like
haven't seen more live-action screen
like this so I thought it was a great
choice and I would love to see them
again so just looking at you now like
get that that Cebu I'm ready haha thank
you so much so thank you can you sit
down with us I had a great time with the
movie I can't wait further people to see
it oh thank you thanks so much